it's nine months since the jungle was
bulldozed enclosed Nature has reclaimed
the space once home for 10,000 people
but the drawer hasn't gone beyond the
port road the migrants keep on coming
almost all our young men lots under 18
it's hard to know for sure how many are
here they move every night
it's cat-and-mouse with the police the
authorities objective seems to be to
keep them moving disrupt any attempt
they make to set up another camp to
submit them into registering in an
official centre it's hard line but from
the government's point of view it's
logical but then so too is the migrants
refusal to comply take Osman from
Afghanistan he's been in Germany for the
past two years legitimately trying to
claim asylum
I speak gentleman very well and I work
in them and after two years he told me
he limited you can go other country
except he can't like most here he stands
little chance of asylum anywhere in
Europe now because one country has
already registered and rejected him
still they all think the UK will be
different that somehow there's hope
there I just really don't know what
should we do for 16 year old Khaled Shah
this should be listen to his story
my father is British he born in UK but
my mom she's from Afghanistan and now my
mum she is no more
and my father he is in England he's
British he want to support me here
illegally but I wouldn't take a lawyer
here they doesn't work that's why I came
here now to call us and try to track but
the people here the police they say it's
not illegally we don't have a future
here but the UK government they didn't
understand why they didn't take underage
boys from here to UK is he telling the
truth here now we can't be sure the
point is there's no one here listening
to him assessing him and so this is
their answer they don't even wait until
night as some climbed the back others
look for hiding places underneath the
driver seems unfazed he's used to it
it's happening all the time
[Applause]
the police arrived
well that was pretty short-lived the
police turned up very very quickly
they've arrested one person he's under
18 and so he's been handed over to some
child services he'll take him to a
center in another town and the police
have now moved on by early evening the
cost of this reckless desperation is
clear in town a small group of eretrians
have gathered with volunteers to
remember their friend killed the night
before falling from a truck in Kali's
North cemetery numbers mark the graves
of some of those who've died trying to
get to the UK at least 40 migrants have
been killed since 2015 a Polish truck
driver also died this year his lorry
crashed after migrants tried to stop it
Calais is just a snapshot it's the same
at borders across the continent move
them on hope they become someone else's
problem here though it's the end of the
line unless they chance it on the trucks
mark stone Sky News in Calais